[Music]
what up guys goes in here for anime
uproar and today we are going to be
explaining every quirk from class 1a I'm
excited to finally do this video because
I'm truly fascinated by all the
different quirks and their unique
abilities if you guys like my hero
academia want to see more my hero
academia video smash that like button
and if you're new don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification mill
also I want to shut our fellow YouTube
bro Briggs from all-day anime he's
already made a bunch of awesome videos
explaining individual characters like
kakugo and eraser head so be sure to
check out his channel link in the
description now for each student I will
list the name of his or her quark and
the quark type I will also explain how
the quark works and list any notable
techniques if you guys want to see a
specific character discussed in more
detail let us know in the comment
section below along with any other
suggestions you may have all right now
without further ado let's do this c1 we
have yoga a yama his quirk is called
naval laser and his quirk type is
emitter naval laser as you'd expect
allows you get to shoot lasers from his
navel aka his bellybutton yoga can shoot
short-range or long-range beams
depending what the situation calls for
the recoil can be powerful enough to
propel yoga through the air at a high
speed with his specially designed
costume you guys able to channel his
laser and fire beams from locations
other than his bellybutton such as from
his knees or shoulders in seat number 2
we have Mina Ishida her quirk is called
acid and her core type is emitter the
quirk let's recreate a corrosive liquid
from her skin she can control the liquid
solubility and discuss it in addition to
asked attacks she can use the liquid to
make the ground slippery which allows
her to slide across at four melt parts
of a wall to make it easier to climb
fork work alters her skin segments
resulting in a purplish color a drawback
of her quirk is that if she makes a
small mistake her clothes may be
dissolved by accident and named
techniques include acid veil in seat
number three we had to you Asli her
quirk is called frog form and her quirk
type is music this quirk allows her to
jump vast distances like a frog cling to
walls
extremely fast camouflage herself and
used her long and powerful tongue as a
weapon true you can produce a toxin from
her stomach and she can also use her
stomach to store objects and bring them
back up when she needs them mmm
tasted because her body is similar to a
frog and frogs are cold-blooded to you
is sensitive to cool temperatures and
being exposed to them for too long would
make her tired and unable to fight
effectively conceit number four we have
our class president himself pena EDA the
name of his quirk is engine and the type
is mutant his quirk lets him move
extremely fast because of engines that
are growing out of the calves on his
legs and his legs are also extremely
strong so he relies on them for
attacking his opponent with quick and
powerful kicks funny enough his engines
are fueled by orange juice and the
engines also have multiple gears that he
moves through in order to accelerate
faster in seed 5 we have the girl that
makes that goo sweat more than any
villain ever could Oh chucka Oh chucka
the name of her quirk is zero gravity
and the type is emitted her quirk allows
her to make objects float in the air as
if they were in zero gravity
just by touching them if she closes her
fingers or chaco can cancel out the
effects of her quirk and send the
floating object falling to the ground
she cannot make objects that weigh more
than three tons float and if she exerts
herself too much she will feel sick and
if she makes herself float by using the
quirk on her own body
she is also likely to feel sick because
of it known techniques include skill
release and home run comets in seed 6 we
have lishchyna or judo the name of his
quirk is tail and the type is mutant
simply put he has a really strong tail
that can destroy even the hardest
objects like metal and he can also use
it to jump off the ground with great
force and to climb more easily since the
tail is always a part of him it
sometimes gets in his way
when he is trying to sit down or lie
down normally in seat 7 we had dankey
community the name of his quirk is
electrification and the type is emitter
thank you releases electricity out of
his body and anyone that comes into
contact with it is electrocuted when he
releases enough electricity it is
discharged in every direction shocking
everyone close to his quirk would be
very useful for
or mean because it lets the possessor
activate or charge electronics no more
need for portable batteries when we're
playing pokemon go
hopefully someone out there is still
playing pokemon go a drawback to this
quirk is that it thankee exceeds his
wattage limit he short circuits his own
brain and as a result he becomes a dunce
for one hour he was unable to fight back
until he recovers from being a baka
his core does not match up well with
quirks that don't conduct electricity
like mine and it does not work on other
people with electric based quirk in seat
eight we have a Jiro Kirishima the name
of his quirk is hardening and the type
is transformation hey doodles quirk
let's impart at any part of his body it
makes for a great offense and defect
not only does this hardening protect him
from physical attacks it can also
protect him from heat or shockwaves
thanks to his quirk a judo was alright
after several tons of metal fell on him
there is an important drawback to this
impressive quirk there is a limit to the
amount of damage the hardened skin can
take before the hardening begins to
slowly weaken main techniques include
red counter red right unbreakable and
red godless in seat 9 we have quadri
Kota the name of his quirk is animal
voice and a type is emitter his quirk is
sound bass any animal within vocal range
will follow his oral command a drawback
is that louder noises can drown out his
voice making his quirk useless Koji can
control insects but this control is less
effective because insects creep them out
in C 10 we have Aikido sato the name of
his quirk is sugar rush and the type is
emitted if he ingest 10 grams of sugar
the kiddos strength will multiply by 5
and the effects will last for 3 minutes
he can keep increasing the time limit by
another 3 minutes by ingesting another
10 grams of sugar but there's a catch
which there has to be or we would have
kids all over the world consuming crazy
amounts of sugar in order to acquire
superhuman strength the catch is that
the sugar makes him dumber
so now Thank You Nicki bill can be bakas
together in seed 11 we have metal Shoji
the name of his quirk is blue planet is
transformation his tentacle-like arms
are able to duplicate other parts of his
body including his eyes ears and mouth
new body parts are created using the
quirks are improved versions of the
originals and can be
used to give meso better sight hearing
and strength one tentacle-like arm can
duplicate more than one body part at a
time but if more than one part is
duplicated as once then these parts have
less efficiency is that a single
duplicated part would have this is
definitely an amazing work even if it is
a little gross in c12 we have Keuka judo
the name of her quirk is earphone jack
and the type is music kyoka has ear
lobes shaped like audio jacks and she
can insert them into various places in
order to channel the sound of her
heartbeat into them which produces
powerful vibration the quirk also gives
her the useful ability of hearing
through thick objects such as walls the
boots of her hero costume have speaker
and outlets into which kyoka can plug
her jacks and this enables her to create
a powerful sound wave and aim it at her
opponent the jacks can stretch for up to
6 meters in her themselves strong enough
to shatter hard objects like rock in c13
we have han tenido the name of his quark
is tape and its type is music his quirk
allows hunter to shoot tape from his
elbow including more than one strand of
tape at a time and he can also retract
them back into his elbows once he no
longer needs them the tape is actually
very strong and can be very useful in
battle both for wrapping up opponents
and for using them to swing around in
the air
spider-man style the amount of tape
hanta can discharge at any given time
has a limit and if he uses too much of
it he will suffer physical consequences
such as dry skin in c14 we have fumika
gay Takuya me his quirk is dark shadow
and its type is transformation the quirk
allows him to emit a shadow like
creature from his body and he can then
use this creature in battle dark shadow
is actually sent him and even able to
speak on its own and after uses up a
certain amount of energy it has to
return inside fumika gaze body to
recharge dark shadow is said to be
affected by fumika gaze emotions and it
is also affected by light the quirk is
weaker in strong light and stronger in
the absence of light but when it is
stronger it is also harder to control
controlling dark shadow can be difficult
in the absence of light but it is very
important if he is unable to control it
dark shadow can actually completely take
over
fumika gaze body in seed 15 we have the
very cool shuttle Todoroki the name of
his quark is how cold half hot and the
type is emitter as the name suggests
so the Rockies quark is divided into his
right side allows him to freeze objects
and opponents while his left side allows
him to release burning flames
technically so the rookie is able to use
both sides of his quark at the same time
but he chooses the favor to right or
cold side heavily as a way of rejecting
his father from whom he inherited the
hot side of his quark however when he
over uses his cold side while trying not
to use the hot one so the Rocky risks
getting frostbite one of his known
attacks includes giant ice wall in sweet
16 we have total Hikaru in the name of
her quark is transparency and its type
is mutant it allows her to be completely
invisible to the naked eye but since her
court doesn't affect the clothing she
wears this means that in order to be
totally invisible she has to be totally
naked her quark appears to work on the
basis of manipulating life because along
with being able to appear invisible she
can also create blinding flashes of
light and use these flashes as a weapon
against her opponents in c---seventeen
we have the explosive kutsuki bakugan
the name of his quark is explosion and
his quark type is emitter so our
resident hotheads quark allows him to
use sweats which is similar to
nitroglycerin from the palms of his
hands to create explosions the more buck
will sweat the more powerful the
explosions are because there is more
nitroglycerin like sweat to ignite as
you'd expect hot weather is optimal for
buccal growth work while in cold weather
the sweat takes longer to ignite but
Google's quark has proven to be quite
versatile aside from using it to create
deadly attacks but google has used his
quark to maneuver in the air the
drawback is that prolonged use of the
quark especially after a large explosion
will eventually wear out the possessors
palm name techniques include blast rush
turbo stun grenade howitzer impact and
AP shot in seat 18 we have the
plain-looking but lovable azúcar
midoriya aka deck although he was
quickly at first the name of his current
work is one for all and its type is
emitter one for all it's a transferable
quark that our protagonist got from all
Mike it is the union of two quirks one
that stockpiles power and another that
allows quirks to be transferred
to other people one for all can
temporarily give the possessor
superhuman strength and speed out of all
the quirks in the class I see that this
one is the most powerful but this is
also why it is the hardest to master
that will have to go through intense
training before he can inherit the power
and even then the raw power of the quirk
causes him to continuously injure
himself when he uses it it was important
to note that one for all is still a bit
of a mystery during his match with he
Toshi himself the lingering presence of
those who had the quick before Deku
seemed to activate one for all which
released Deku from heat oh she is quark
so it seems like at times one for all
can act on its own in seed 19 we have my
favorite student
Minoru Mineta the name of his quark is
Popoff and it's type is music this quark
allows him to literally pop off sticky
balls from the top of his head and use
them as weapon if he is creative about
it although they don't stick to me no
though the balls stick to other surfaces
and can remain sticky for up to 24 hours
once he pops one of the balls off his
head a new one will grow back in its
place but if he pops off too many in a
short period of time he will actually
begin to bleed one of his known attacks
includes grape rush where he just runs
towards the forint and throws the sticky
balls at them in the hopes of mobilizing
them with the stickiness and finally in
seat number 20 we have Momo euro euro zu
the name of her quark is creation and
its type is emitter with her quark she
is able to literally create objects
including weapons out of her body as
long as her skin is exposed in that
particular spot she cannot create living
things but as long as she is familiar
with the atomic makeup of an object she
can make it by breaking down the fat in
her body on a molecular level and
reshaping it into the desired object the
bigger the object she wants to produce
the more of her skin needs to be exposed
which can lead to some tricky situations
for mobile so there you have it guys
every quark in class 1-a explain thanks
for watching and like I said if you have
any suggestions for future videos leave
them in the comments if you enjoyed this
video Detroit smash that like button and
subscribe for more videos until next
time see you space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]